check out this week's must-see me you  understand that you were charged with  operating an illegal gambling business  in Molly's game a former competitive  athlete runs an exclusive high-class  poker game which makes her an FBI target  that's gonna make noise when I was a boy  I started to hide things and the linings  of the garments in Phantom thread  romance disrupt say Fame dressmakers  life stop playing this game what  precisely is the nature of my game  bankrupt better luck with your next job  inspired by the life of PT Barnum the  greatest showman celebrates nothing less  than the birth of modern show business  no one ever made a difference by being  like everyone else see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fan tissa  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]